39 39看看
非常好看
非常清爽
39你看你要不
后面是封地扣
有隐形拉链有松紧腰的
来吧
我跟你说面料舒服的很
我这样往腿上一放
舒服的很
你看你喜欢吗
喜欢的话你就扣个3
晚安鱼
喜欢的话就扣个3哦
来这一款条纹的
短袖有扣有扣牙
好看的腰围合适
有没有长
有别的款长的
这个款没有长的了
这个款就这
就这个长度亲爱的
你想要长裙还是想要
花的长裙是吧
我得给你找一找
这种花的长的是没有
有别的款
有一色的
有一色的长的
有一个这个不知道你小不小
GL的那个白色的长这个
这个很长
看看
但是这个是小码
但是他这个是小码
他没有拉链
但是他这里啊
弹力很大
我这个我都能穿
这我都能穿弹力很大
这个长裙你喜欢吗
白色的底
黑色的花
黑色的钩花的
这个你喜欢吗
晚安鱼小妹妹
看看
这个你喜不喜欢
这个但是他只有S码
这个我现在是秒杀价
原来是39的
这个因为现在只有这一个小码了
所以放福利了
我给你量一下
你听听
如果要的话9块
9块
腰围的话是60
但是可以拉伸到84
唇围不限
裙长100
这个要的话9块
9块扣零
要的话就去扣
来这款男生穿的这个条纹的这个
有裤有裤牙
条纹的这个上衣
面料很舒服的
面料是锯纸的
锯纸锯纸
来胸围胸围
长度75
来谁要9块9块
扣5
9块9块
谁要谁来扣个5
扣5扣5了
来这一款来这一款我们看一下
这个白色白色白色S码前面咱不是过了个绿色吗
这是一个白的看看
来这款有裤有裤牙腰式松紧要两边有鞋拉兜裤脚卷边裤脚卷边屁股后面光满没有口袋的啊
来这一款面料滑滑的薄薄的啊
来腰围64合一组的
腰围64可以拉伸到84
腿围100可以拉到106
当场35当场35裤长87
来这种裤子谁要9块9块扣7
9元9元谁要谁来扣个7
9块9块
来这个棒球服L码L码啊
他是巨值95尼龙5巨值95尼龙5来这个卡吉色的这个棒球服
哎
这个等等那个漂亮威尼熊来了
跟他这个儿子能不能穿
这我看一下应该够胸围132胸围132长度的话是74
来这个原来是49的啊
现在2929扣盖
我给他留一留留一留这个他要的话
看他要不要他都是要这种大的
来来来来走过路过不要错过了啊
来全棉的这个衬衫
棉100年100元领元领前面短一点后面长一点全棉100的全棉100
来这款绣的是松紧的啊
可以长可以短袖子
咱们可以往上拉来这款全棉全棉胸围胸围116118116118长度前面63后面73
这个我和田儿我们都自留了全棉咱们有很多老粉姐姐啊
都有的囤个两三件呢
这个咱们谁要1919扣1扣1啊
来喜欢姐姐就扣19扣1扣1扣1啊
好的
超级好这个来天呢
谢谢小妹394
谢谢亲爱的小妹妹来321好
谢谢
来这个也是男生穿的一个外套
L嘛
他是巨只63
呃绵32
然后聚氨酯5%
他的牌子是这个牌
牌子是这个牌子的姐妹们啊
妈你有码数吗
他那个是没有标了
只有一个样一的一个牌
但是他肯定是 m 码
如果是 s 码的话
他的腰围就是在62
这样子啊
我再给你看一下好吗小妹啊
好吗
我再给你看一下好吧
c
他没有标了
哎啊啊他他有标
但是标上面啥也没写
看到了吗
有标但是他上面啥也没写
他只有一个这个样一标
他估计可能是这个牌子的吧
可能是这个牌子的
只有一个这个样一标啊
是这样的你看看
但是好看
好看的
你看这个腰围的话在64
应该是 m 如果是 s 的话腰围在62
原来这个啊
后面还有松紧
所以这种裙子穿着腰舒服
如果腰上面没有松紧的话
没有那么舒服
啊这个特别清爽夏天穿
没事你考虑一下要的话你跟我说好吧
就这一条了
全部卖完了
BARK BLUE
来这个小西装外套
灰色灰色
没有扣
没有9也没有—呀
少空少空小
来有口袋
后面彼边开场
来这一款咱们来量下谁要
家里边有男生能穿的啊
这个咱们9块9块
扣6
胸围胸围
106 110
腰围94 100
94 100
衣长71
来这款谁要9块9块
扣3扣3
来这个灰色面料舒服的很啊
面料舒服的很啊
男生穿的
很薄的很薄
你看袖子长
来谁要谁来扣9块9块
扣0
9块扣0
这个咱们家云海和有小星星
他们都买了
很多姐姐买了
里边全部包边的
里边全部包边
9块9块
扣0扣0
来这个牌子的
这个牌子
这个牌子的
这个是一个
调牌价是10450
10450面料是锯纸的
面料是锯纸锯纸的
来这个面料锯纸的有拉链有拉链的来这个外套
这个外套春秋都可以穿的来胸围
胸围
108 110
腰围和胸围是一样的啊
来长度长度101
长度101
来这款谁要4949扣8
两边有口袋
有吊牌有标啊
49谁要谁来扣个8吊牌价一万多的啊
姐妹们啊
10450的
吊牌价是10450的
来来来
来这个牛仔裙短裙
他这里是有做了两只这种处于中腰的中腰的啊
左边有隐形拉链
没有口袋
来这一款咱们来量一下
你们听一下
M码年八十就指18捐至2%来腰围六十八七十四腿为8892群长45来9块9块扣5
9块9块谁要谁来扣个五
谁要谁来扣个五
来这个米色威领领领子后面少一个裤子有扣牙少扣啊
这个可以给你们配个裤
你们回家自己缝一下威领米色来这个上衣面料锯纸面料锯纸的来我来量一下
胸围胸围一百一百零二一百一百零二长度前面54后面56来9块9块扣七
九元九元谁要谁来扣个七
谁要谁来扣个七
九块九块扣七
来这个白衬衫
我这里还有一件哦
还有一件这个白衬衫全棉全棉的
他的袖子是可以这样穿的
姐妹们看我穿的时候
基本上都是拉到这个位置
我觉得舒服
原来这里是这种松紧的啊
来这款谁要谁来扣胸围116118长度前面六十三七后面七十三来谁要谁来扣1919扣二1919扣二啊
扣二扣二
这个是M码M码
谁要谁来扣1919扣个二扣个二
来这一款吉亚L的这个是L码
L码
年三十五巨值六十五腰上有抽绳腰上松紧腰有抽绳
底边是松紧的
来腰为六十四可以拉到九十二腿为110可以拉到116110116当场三十五当场三十五裤长九十三来这个裤子谁要二十九二十九扣个二二十九谁要谁来扣个二
谁要谁来扣个二来喜欢
你一共二十九扣个二
来这个条纹的翻领条纹的翻领条纹的翻领看看有腰带有腰带的面料聚酯的来这个连衣裙面料聚酯面料聚酯啊来腰上面有一点点
松紧的啊
来胸围胸围胸围九十二可以拉到九十八九十二九十八来腰围六十八七十二六十八可以拉到七十二来群长群长来九十五群长九十五来这个群的二十九二十九扣五二十九二十九谁要谁来扣个五
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
来半裙又来啦半身裙又来啦
半身裙又来一包
来这个这个藏青色的直筒裙有一点点小a字哎呦这个裙子不行了吗
哎呦这个裙子不行了吗
没问题吓死我了
这是个线头
我以为抽丝了呢
来后面有隐形拉链的来这个群
我来量一下腰围腰围七十六七十八囤围